okay let's return to the collapse of the
ceasefire in eastern Ukraine and John
Herbst of the Atlantic Council think
tank who's also a former US ambassador
to Ukraine joins me now from Washington
thank you for joining us
so debaltsevo seems to be a bit of a
problem for both the Ukrainian soldiers
and the Russians supported rebels this
is going to be a problem isn't it for
the the ceasefire well I think you can
lay the blame squarely at the foot of
the Kremlin let's remember that the
ceasefire that was agreed on Thursday
was supposed to go into effect
immediately
but the separatists and the Kremlin said
no and he agreed to have two and a half
day delay before the ceasefire went into
effect and then the rebels with Kremlin
support tried to take the town but have
you very heavy fighting before the
ceasefire learned to affect when they
failed the separatists announced that
the ceasefire did not really apply to
debaltsevo which is very strange
definition of a ceasefire they reply
everywhere except for the place where
most of the Fighting's going on so very
clearly a violation by the Russians then
they're their puppets in Ukraine so what
can be done I guess mr. Putin where is
easy and hungry at the moment and he's
commenting on all of this very much
leading from the front what about Angela
Merkel and mr. Hollande is there
anything they can say that will be will
be heard by mr. Putin yes they should
claim that he is violating the ceasefire
and there could be no sanctions relief
because they is violating the ceasefire
that would be heard very loud and clear
in the Kremlin does not seem to take any
notice to anybody what can the u.s. do
and they did say that they were thinking
about delivering arms to the Ukrainian
soldiers to offer them support well I
think that would be very good thing I
believe the United States should have
long ago supply weapons defensive lethal
weapons to the Ukrainians to make it
harder for the Russians commit more
aggression in Ukraine to take more
territory in Ukraine and if you were to
join that would make the message even
stronger
so is this just been a diplomatic waste
of time then well I think it
demonstrates that one side is interested
in having a piece and the other side is
not in that sense there's some value in
it but I don't think mr. Putin will be
dissuaded by diplomacy he will only be
dissuaded by strong action the United
States and Europe in harmony against his
aggression in Ukraine just remind us
ambassador hips what is mr. Putin
gaining from eastern Ukraine why is this
such a prize for him well here I should
start by saying he has nowhere said to
anyone in the West what he would do
should be what conditions he needs for
peace his motivation he kept his kept
deliberately dark my belief is this he
would like to have a compliant
government in Keith if he cannot have a
compliant government if he wants to
stabilize Ukraine so that the government
Keith cannot successfully establish a
democracy a market economy and align its
natural national security policies with
Europe to do that he needs to go further
and further into Ukraine so that there's
never any stability in the country that
I believe is objective so this is mr.
Putin's war on European values then
absolutely this is what he does not want
well let's keep in mind this has little
to do or nothing to do with NATO this
all began because Europe and Judah the
European Union and Ukraine were talking
about signing a trade agreement this is
how this began do you think people
outside and I'm talking about the West
here and the EU are they being too
hesitant with mr. Putin absolutely they
are treating him like one of them
countries that are interested or leaders
are interested in instability and in
peace if said mr. Putin is a revisionist
he has stated that he has the right and
the duty to protect ethnic Russians and
Russian speakers wherever they may live
and many live in Ukraine many live in
the Baltic countries many live in
Kazakhstan many
he has also said that the rules created
in the post Cold War or to have to
change or there will be no rules so he
has very clear objectives to change the
rules which means change the board as
established ad at the end of the Cold
War he did it in Georgia he's trying to
do it now in Ukraine and he will go
beyond Ukraine if he is successful in
Ukraine okay ambassador Herbst thank you
very much for your insight there thank
you